What you see here is a representation of all the classes in Firefox.
Every class here in this picture is a rectangle.
The larger the rectangle, the more lines of code in that class.
These rectangles are nested into folders and packages.
The color of the rectangle indicates how many security issues have been fixed
in that particular class.
What we see here, for instance, is the document object model,
which has a fair share of security fixes.
But there is more areas with plenty of security issues.
Here we have JavaScript.
Here we do have HTML layout.
Here we have a library for displaying the content.
Now for the quiz.
Which of these four packages has had the most security issues in the past?
Is it JavaScript? Is it HTML layout?
Is it the DOM? Or is the content base?